you said i've never had a bad egg roll
you are insane dude i i honestly think
that egg roll is something that is made
very consistently everywhere no
no no no and here's why you're wrong
it's made consistently in new york area
and new jersey and pet and philadelphia
area chinese restaurants you start to go
to chinese places that don't have the
the american chinese culture of food
that we have here you go to l.a and try
to get an egg roll it ain't happening
tuts
it ain't happening
who are you talking to an egg roll is
way more consistent than trim cocktail
and for the most part when i get an egg
roll
it's a delicious
crunchy thing that i wanted in the
tri-state area and i run a lot of things
i don't want when i order shrimp go to
go to canada and tell me how the egg
rolls are up there go up to canada try
to go to canada i'll tell you why i live
here i'll get it i'll get a shrimp
cocktail in canada i'll be pretty
goddamn i'm happy why are we talking
about flying to another country i